i'm about to send you down memory lane
this is something that only true fans of
my channel would even know about did you
know
i have another youtube channel
one that you
may never have seen before welcome to
markiplier twitch
now before i get into this i need to
explain some things about markiplier
twitch this was my
twitch tv archive channel and on this
channel is a video called markiplier
dies a lot in super meat boy just tired
not drunk
tired not drunk anyway
whatever i'm gonna try to get all the
bandages so apparently i was very tired
today i don't know why but i was tired i
can't remember specifically it was nine
years ago give me a break i wonder what
the newest comment is it's weird seeing
comments from five years ago i found it
i finally found it every year since this
was posted i've been recommended this
video throughout my many different
accounts i made this video followed me
through them 22 minutes ago nisanus was
deleted and i felt comfort that youtube
decided to recommend something that has
been here since i've been watching
videos memento mori well i might delete
it who knows
but if you go through this channel
markiplier twitch you'll see some uh
true beginnings you'll even see uh the
very first drunk minecraft even before
drunk minecraft was a series and even
before i discovered that i wasn't
actually able to drink also me playing
dead space 2 hardcore and then well i
won't spoil the ending for you also me
playing scp-087 also me playing diablo
3. a lot of very early stuff on my
channel
not even on my channel but among this is
super meat boy and you know what game is
out i've gone deaf in my left ear
and but
it's back kind of you know what else is
here super meat boy forever oh wait
why's that muted
because i muted
uh lexie please adjust that to a nominal
level so it's not deafening it's very
loud but also if you didn't know
something about me is that i'm very good
at platformers i don't know why but of
all the games that i play one of them
that i am best at is platformers and if
there's one thing that super meat boy is
it's a platformer so i'm gonna play it
god damn it's loud
oh okay there we go all right so i'm
gonna play this um and i'm gonna win
this is if you don't know about
okay if you don't know about super meat
boy it's a very difficult game now super
meat boy forever i believe is an endless
and also randomly generated game
i don't know what that means
but we're about to find out
[Music]
ain't that sweet
oh my god
holy crap
it's the super mario rpg intro
oh my god i love super mario rpg that is
that is literally a recreation of the
super mario rpg intro which
if you've never played super mario rpg
incredible game
lovely game fantastic game all right how
do i play
uh huh
what button is that
down ah down right right
that makes perfect sense that it would
be down and slide
oh one fundamental difference about this
game versus the other games is that
you are always running to the right
which is definitely something oh
okay wait i see something here
no hang on
i see something
no there's no way
okay it's getting a little ridiculous
now all right whatever
i thought there might been a way to get
above everything
oh you can go the other way
oh interesting
oh okay there we go
okay
okay that was my baby you just punched
all right
so humble oh humble beginnings
obviously it's not going to be too
terribly difficult to hear in
the opening sequences
they're going to be relatively gentle to
me
but i don't know if this is random
hey
nice
oh how do i deal with that how do i deal
with that
oh
ow
i'm trying to thread this gap here no
there's no way i just want to see if
it's possible
no no way
okay
nice i say to myself
nice nice i say nice i did
nice
oh my god how
how
oh i see oh okay okay i see
oh
you really gotta make sure you get the
absolute apex of your
height of your jump or else you're not
gonna get what you need
okay okay okay
it's kinda okay okay this is where the
game gets a little bit more difficult
because it's in the precision of it okay
that was my baby still that you just
obliterated or whatever because it don't
matter
wow
nice
yeah i get that
wow
i get that you know it's kind of hard to
see what i'm doing when you're doing
that
nice
okay okay
oh
oh god
ah
okay
combo moves do i get any bonus points
for oh
god
i ow
yeah oh no oh no
oh no oh no
okay i see what i need to do okay so i
need to jump over that before i get to
the last one so that i retain that one
so i can land on it yeah this isn't
going to be tricky or complicated or
anything like that
interesting
[Music]
okay okay okay we got this
i'm gonna go ahead and fast forward
through all this uh earl okay i'm gonna
fast let's just assume that all the baby
tutorial stuff
is uh well taken care of and i handled
it perfectly
so you guys can find me once i get to
the actual tough stuff be right back
now
whoa okay that's a problem
i don't know if this is randomly
generated but it sure doesn't seem like
it if it is this is incredible
oh no no
you guys aren't even watching this why
are you why are you still here
ah criminy
why
ow
oh no
wow
now
what
damn it
damn it nice precision
okay everyone hush up you're not even
supposed to be here so don't even worry
about it
okay
i've run
i am god damn
i'm goddamn brilliant oh my god you'll
never get me oh you go up
okay
ow guys go away this isn't the tough
stuff shush i'm just gonna
hurry
oh ow
okay right here
this is this is definitely it this is
the one
ow
okay
oh my god
no
okay pause let me go
there we go there
run oh my god
okay we're fine
well all right guys welcome back to okay
welcome back to super meat boy forever
this is uh now you're oh okay now you're
welcome to watch because before you
definitely
okay well now you're able to watch
because definitely before you were not
welcome to because if you were watching
before you weren't watching at the right
time and then
lixie and bro oh blixian probably didn't
uh edit it properly which you know lixie
and uh you know not the
not the most uh attention to
detail-oriented person you know and i
mean we all know lixie and uh
you know uh just
always letting things
slip maybe okay i have an idea well how
about i don't be stupid about it
yeah okay that makes much more sense hey
you miss me
you'll never miss me oh my god
love it love it
listen there's some things that i love
and one of them is this right here right
now
oh my timing is impeccable
okay we're fine
ah come on
my timing is impeccable
this is great this is great for me this
is great for me and my blood pressure
that's great for me this game is hey oh
it's a pacifier
oh
why would you do that
okay please no no yes i mean no okay
this
is in no way gonna be worth it there's
no way this will be worth it
oh why would i be going that way i don't
know whatever shut up
the fires of hell
no
no no no no no
[Applause]
all right i guess i'm not getting that
one guess i'm not getting it
oh my god oh god okay well the trick is
going to be not to go backwards
[Music]
here we go here we go ah through the gap
okay hey guys welcome back to another
we're fine oh god no no
no
it's fine it's fine if you just do
nothing it's fine i just always panic
hey guys it's me again welcome back to
another episode of
super meat boy forever
most plot
[Music]
oh i remember this thing
oh i remember
oh i remember ah yeah of course
a classic unless this wasn't a classic
and i don't even know what i'm talking
about anymore which might be entirely
true
hey that's a baby well i guess you're a
baby so i guess it's all the same
it's all fair i suppose
all right guys
oh my god
and i'm alive i thought i was dead
oh cool oh whoops
oh my god
oh wow okay i know what i'm supposed to
do
okay
all right interesting
nice
oh you
oh oh combos
oh god damn it boss fight in mode engage
which means try hard markiplier mode has
been established
which everyone know oh my god no i did
that to myself
why would i dive bomb head first into
the abyss i don't know here i go i did
it again
wow that was good
oh my god i'm a god
i'm a freaking guy i'm gonna die
you can really wail on him
it's kind of cool
no aha
oh god please not like this
oh my god please give me yes yes
i'm a god
[Music]
yes look at that 26 seconds nine to i
did better on the boss than i did every
any one of those ow
oh god that was only level one
oh good
perfect perfect
nice i wonder if the entire concept is
that you can get through any of these
without dying which i bet some people
have and can and do
but me not quite
i don't know what game that was
replicating but i bet it's gonna be an
equally memorable game to super mario
rpg which is definitely a great game to
remember hey hold on a second here
how you doing
you having a good day what is happening
in the background over there
is there lore happening there wouldn't
be lore happening with there
no no no there's no lore
oh that's freaking cute that's pretty
cute anyway that is
it for this episode of super meat boy
forever i'm getting back into the swing
of things we have finished filming which
means that there's a lot of
post-production to do in terms of
editorial but gonna be getting back into
the schedule here so thank you everybody
so much for watching hope you enjoyed
this if you want to watch more super
meat boy you can always check out my
other channel with my other video
of super b-boy on it the channel that
you didn't know about until this moment
maybe thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you